We are currently getting the outer bands of Hurricane Helene right now,
and because of that, our property was hit by a tornado this morning.
And when situations like this happen,
I always try to find the god moments
because there's so much bad that we could dwell on,
but I try to find, okay,
what good came out of the situation.
So our property is a family compound.
Currently, my in laws live there and our construction offices there,
and we have been trying to build our house there since January,
but we've had so many issues with permitting
and fighting with the county,
so we've kind of put it on pause,
bought a different house while we fight the process.
Well, we have not understood why,
with everything that we have done,
it just wasn't working. Like, Lord,
what are you doing? What are you trying to show us?
Why are you pausing these plans?
Like, it just doesn't make sense.
Well, today,
the path that the tornado took
would have gone right through the middle of our house.
So had we been able to start on our plans,
and in our timing,
we either would have been towards the end of construction,
or we would have just moved in.
So either we would have been out hundreds of thousands of dollars
and had to restart our house,
or we would have been living in it and had catastrophic damage to us
personally. So even though it sucks,
And it's a bad situation, trying to find the good.
And can definitely see, like,
the god moment and his Protection in that moment for us.